[Music]
in dad wingman news Oh baby why why is
that creepy why is that creepy
everyone's like my dad with me I'm
trying to trying to get laid but what
about Tiger he's like 18 I go with them
to a lot of guys a little bit different
but like god of girls
yeah like the dads just like yo man like
you have a huge dick in the family
though like my daughter man I've seen
that [ __ ] like I mean that very weird
when you change diapers that's disgust I
know that if I said it's weird
hey Paige now there's another way you
can look at it is that yo a wingman talk
about the privates all the time well
they're trying to get you hooked up and
just whatever strategy gets you later
what the dad accepts the guy then you
know he's really got acceptance sure a
dad was arrested after driving teens to
the park so they could do their thing oh
my lord what a dope dad was he watching
dope debt why didn't he let drive them
to their house so they could do their
thing is that safer and why did he get
in trouble maybe the wife was like not
in the house they're [ __ ] in public
couches you don't care right
if our kid wanted to get laid somewhere
not my house his room no [ __ ] no is he
cleaning why he had to drum to us I'm
taking you to the park my car I'm gonna
beat your [ __ ] ass tyka if she
finds out she will women find everything
out
hello not true very true yeah you can't
have anything well I'm a bio RV and you
can bug in there yeah with what money
dude what I mean what do you mean when
people hear about my sad story they're
gonna go you're gonna make a gulf I mean
I could buy our view it you already got
a dollar from me man you sold me a
dollar and you high ball in dude right
so this story here it takes place in
Michigan Florida oh my god laura de man
is awesome it has to happen in a while
we should move to Florida
okay nevermind because alligators all of
many reasons
okay then Floridians awesomeland news
should pay Florida for giving them
content
I was trying to be respectful peanuts
and there's like a little piece largely
that's that's in your throat Wow Jess
Wow do you just let the book class here
okay please leave those comments outside
put nuts in her ovaries we make babies
with his nuts yeah but like the ideal
whoa anyway back to the story here I
guess like two nut in one's mouth you
know you quoting Shakespeare one who
nuts to not invite throat is my destiny
yeah I don't know yeah alright so this
dude this father he drove his 15 year
old son to go pick up his 15 year old
girlfriend and then he drove them to the
park so they can do their thing sounds
like some [ __ ] ages yeah I was not
[ __ ] a 15 thank you very much but
it's also good at the same age like an
18 year old guy with like a 15 year old
girl like because what if he was like
picking up a 50 year old due to [ __ ] his
daughter that's weird like one of the
grounds for his arrest is it like a
public place underage so he was arrested
for contributing to the delinquency of a
minor for knowingly and admittedly
driving to fifteen-year-old juveniles to
a park after hours to commit sexual acts
wow that's a long criminal sentence
that's not in the criminal book I'm sure
but a freestyle son or was it his
daughter which one was it
oh that makes sense yeah yeah cuz if it
was a daughter I don't think that would
be happening he told the police he was
like well they aren't they're stealing
they're just having sex yeah and then
when the officer interviews I was like
Bart in the future when the officer
interviewed the two fifteen-year-old
once they returned from the parks soccer
field
oh they did it out in the open on the
soccer field that's
they messed up his son told the cop that
he and the girl were just smoking and
[ __ ] cigarette shop is smoking and
pumpkin oh you're smoking and [ __ ] Oh
Dada da da da see you don't want em
[ __ ] our house our stupid stupid [ __ ]
like that should not be [ __ ] thank you
very well be [ __ ] I had sex about 15
same here [ __ ] all I'm saying they
should not this is my child
I know but may well be that's the thing
take you to a hotel room okay you'll do
hey you know you try to have a bad day
what you're not even gonna know about it
well you already told your secrets and
now she knows if you do something weird
you'll be laser tag later he's trying to
throw you off with like a profession a
mother-to-be playing laser tag
poker night you just lost your ability
to play poker now cuz she's not gonna
let you either no poker no laser tag
knows the person say things like
lingerie bowling I'm gonna be doing
laundry now know what's funny no [ __ ]
use our [ __ ] wash yes he couldn't do
it he asks me for hobbies okay so how do
you turn this on guess what could you
think you do it better than me do it
yeah I you know like the Czech Republic
though like it's like we go have sex
it's like 14 well then Tiger should move
back why would you want to ruin his life
like that there's probably a lot of hot
people there I did dry hump
I cannot [ __ ] but you know you wanted to
oh yes see and I'm glad I didn't though
why because I wasn't I didn't like this
person
why were you dry hump and a person on
life that's really weird your boy I
didn't love this person alright
love someone to dry-hump them geo or to
[ __ ] them what the [ __ ] am I needed a
lot of you I do love you to dry up it's
okay but - foth I was like no no I don't
you can go there huh no I got standards
and move far there's a lot of like like
strong emotions when you're doing this
like news thing with like two couples
it's just whoa what I mean you guys feel
left out over there no no I'm good I'm
gonna enjoy the sidelines definitely a
popular variance part of it Oh like just
the [ __ ] that we talk yeah yeah yeah
that's true I feel the same way too when
I watch other couples like let's say
we're not having a disagreement
oh yeah like when Nicki Steve I go yeah
all even David and Mary or even KC and
if I just like yeah so it's just like
the peripherals are just full right now
you're welcome thank you
seems like you guys want to see a photo
of the day oh yeah I want to see the
couple [ __ ] smoking and [ __ ] not
in the act with the one bad parents or
whatever because this is pretty common
taking kids to the park I mean like
letting kids just [ __ ] in the other room
oh my god I think oh sweet or like
buying cigarettes but that's not I don't
think he would get arrested [ __ ]
drink with us and smoke and then like
everyone [ __ ] inside the house and
[ __ ] like and it's true all parents but
it was the parents that I liked the most
kids now yeah are they bright citizens I
think Bart's right there one of my
friends yeah I know that it's not very
successful gangbanger Coco cellar that
means pretty high up in the chain
[ __ ] Escobar yeah he's very like
white-collar like the way he does his
thinks he's really nice like I always
thought gang like you're a pretty boy
you know like see he was always a nice
person and he's just like my
parents let me smoke and [ __ ] in the
park after hours that was just never
home and then when we when he was he
would just bring cases of beer home for
everybody and then like that's very
irresponsible really one of the most
responsible things that haven't heard
remember that story of that that
McDonald's working mom I thought she was
so cool she's like this because she
smoked so much like all the words a hole
right here no she doesn't have that hole
she just smoked so much her throat was
like that his friend's mom so she's like
after work she would bring home
McDonald's and we would all be smoking
weed and [ __ ] while we're eating
McDonald's with her and then when we get
stoned we would go visit her at
McDonald's and would be like oh hey
what's up hey Jimmy and what are you
saying about her though you're saying
that she's like really white trash but
she sounds cool too yes you good person
white trash we're like [ __ ] fat and
skinny Eminem fat and skinny yeah
they're brothers it was fat and skinny
Eminem I don't even remember their names
but we used to like tag all the time I
write bicycles and then we would smoke
weed together fans get so like they'd be
like the head in the yellow M&M
specifically no like the rapper the
rapper
[Laughter]
wait what do you do for a living is it
anything that has to do with music like
current music maybe I'm trippin he's
hiding who's that the dad I was not
expecting powers in picturing an Indian
man black or Indians
yeah he's either Indian or Ethiopia
Ethiopia I don't know they don't write
his yeah they shouldn't have his name
I'm Katie Lawrence Mitchell he's 53
years old that is hilarious
they're just [ __ ] we were just
smoking and Falken and that's a cool dad
that's the girl
if her dad knew like what was happening
obviously she was like mad but then she
not you know weird I remember I got
stoned with this other mom and then we
were just hanging out and then she's
like you boys hungry and then and then
my friend
he was like yeah ma can you oh can you
make us fried chicken and then I was
like oh my god
she allows us to smoke weed and she
cooks for us and she made some [ __ ]
bomb ass fried chicken conquers your own
the whole time I was like you have the
best family dude [ __ ] and then we would
have the best parties there and then the
mom would just go around and like smoke
all the weed up I'm like dude my family
sucks
they're so Christian and boring and [ __ ]
that's what I thought
[Music]